[Laughter]
just give us a second
what is
all right well we'll finish this later
all right we'll pause it we're positive
enough enough with him enough of the
manuel in space uh the softcore porn
from 1994. so we're here to talk about
uh incredible hulk returns from 1988 uh
a better uh video that we should all
know more about um we're gonna give us
our honest thoughts behind the scenes
about the trailer
we might go back to watching emmanuel
i feel like i've missed a very important
part of my young queer training yeah
london you have let me down we just
broke into the theater we just both
realized that we both know the theme
song
which is a thing to discover
if you've known another man for many
years
that's when it's time to check if you
can take it to the next level the
emmanuel in space just browse being
dudes yeah
we'll also show uh what else do we do uh
we we do deleted scenes uh we're gonna
do a q a so if you have any emmanuel or
hulk or any questions drop them in the
chat uh and then we will tease you with
next week's honest trailer it's a manual
it's manual in space
don't tease me
so uh hulk versus thor aka the
incredible hulk returns um how do you
not put the name thor in your we fixed
that yeah
the fact that they
made your site yeah the whole point of
this thing if i understand correctly
because i was not uh alive to watch
the hulk tv show
it was 78 right oh i thought you were
talking about this no this i was a very
i was pooping myself right yeah um so
the uh hulk tv show ends six years pass
and i guess
as they still do to this day like nbc
was like let's snatch up the rights to
the hulk we need we're gonna we're gonna
make three tv movies and we're gonna
launch a whole new hulka verse um and we
need more characters than just bill
bixby uh so let's let's launch the thor
series that's what this movie was was
made for right
okay so the cast area clearly feels like
a leader we're supposed to be following
the ongoing adventures of thor after
this yeah um
eric kramer is thor he is he is uh i
someone pointed out in the comments he
is little john in men in tights and then
it clicked then it clicked and you're
he's also in lodge 49. he's a regular on
the show lodge 49 which you can now
watch in its entirety on hulu and is
really terrific
one of those like peak tv shows that
just got overlooked in its day wyatt
russell stars in it uh fantastic what's
his marvel name homelander oh no usa usa
usage yeah yeah he's the evil captain
america yeah um so all things uh become
marvel as their want to do um yeah so
i feel like we should just take people
through should we just take people
through the story of this because nobody
watching this watch that they mess up
the thor they make the thor origin and
the thor explanation very confusing so i
feel like we should at least unpack a
little of that
actually let's do it as we watch because
i'm sure there will be moments where we
will stop and explain cause he's who is
who is thought
not my film not my thor
let's play the honors trailer for the
incredible hulk turns aka hulk first
thor 1988. roll it
manuel
queen of the galaxy no one ever asked
for this one and once in a while you
just gotta trust me
so let's crack open the honest trailer
vault for
hulk vs thor
okay officially it's the incredible hulk
returns but we both know no one's
clicking on that
love going back to the vault just that
sound of a vhs yeah comforting
in a world dominated by movies like
superman superman 2 superman 3
and supergirl marvel has surrendered
film to dc and retreated to the small
screen selling spider-man off to the
japanese
spider-man
and using their only past success to try
and launch a new hero thor
look marvel sucks at adapting their
comics but do you realize what this
means they're setting up a made for tv
avengers movie so rad i hope they get
kevin kline for loki or george carlin
maybe cruz
i mean who would have been the marvel
avengers i think that's that's like the
the material for a thousand buzzfeed
articles yeah there's been a lot of a
lot of people trying to sort of like
figure this out we might as well throw
it out there who would the uh who would
the marvel event made for tv 1988 marvel
events wow the made for tv marvel events
i mean they could let's say movie or tv
so you don't have to limit yourself to
just uh like you know peter falk or
whatever
who is near fury
ted danson that's nick theory
who do you got i mean let's do iron man
hulk uh and um you need a captain
america well we already have hulk i
guess we need iron man captain america
let's just do those two
um captain america
oh that's a really you know what i think
iron man maybe like a uh uh uh if you're
going
kind of older um can't remember his name
right now but like that old dude that
was on um the young and the restless he
was the guy who was like the major
villain and everything kind of wasn't a
soap guy
i give up
young and the restless desire you know
i was thinking for captain america but
now that i think about it it's really
he's a thunderbolt ross pick is craig t
nelson coach oh yeah which is craig
you gotta get him in that 80s mcu yeah i
like dancing as iron man ted danson
would be a fantastic guy dancing would
nail it yeah dancing would actually be a
really good iron man yeah uh captain
america it's tough because
america in 1988 was so like
it'd be like um
uh who is
not stallone but um yeah stallone
stallone is captain america i feel like
they could they could squeeze them into
the space i think it would have been
like hulk hogan
it would have been arrested
yeah it probably would have been
honestly maybe like brent hart even
those canadians
i love america e
all right well you let us know in the
comments uh uh who your picks would uh
for those two would have been but uh
let's move on let's keep watching this
years after he wandered down the road
for the last time bill bixby returns
he's still a man on the run hiding the
true identity of david banner under the
alias david banyan my organization
kidnapped david banyan also within the
week was david danner taken he's a
frankenstein trying to perfect his
hulk's direct to be gone so that only
leaves time for him to do two things
science i've turned the transponder into
a kind of giant chinese puzzle and his
co-worker you smell delicious
it tastes pretty good too
sir excuse me sir
the only film written by armie hammer
[Laughter]
the way we uh the way we meet um david
banyan david he's first of all i have to
note he's david bruce back by all three
names a bunch of times which is very
straight pick one yeah we're introduced
to him i i did not know that he was such
a playboy in the in the tv show or was
he or well no it was it was episodic
yeah and every week he's you know he's
getting into different scrapes and
helping people so often he would come to
the aid of a of a woman and they would
develop a feelings for one another that
happened i guess if you are constantly
on the run like he's the original dirty
john yeah
he just had to be like somebody's uh
yeah he's sliding babies like why are
you always wearing those scrubs don't
worry he's sliding into a new situation
you know everywhere i'm going to my
science office to do science
i'm going to work on my uh i love you
he's basically reacher but he can
sometimes take time off being reached i
don't have to stay big all the time well
he's he's managed to not get angry for
the last two years uh according to
himself and he's uh and i see why he's
he's chilling in malibu um
uh just absolutely laying pipe to this
uh uh lovely lady scientist
just the horniest so horny and she it
must be good because she's asking no
questions about his she's ignoring a lot
he's ignoring a whole lot of really
weird stuff that he's saying he's like
you st you told you you were screaming
in your sleep about the monster that's
going to come out what's that about he's
like it's your babe
coffee
but you're like okay also how they're
either she's making a fabulous amount of
money from science or she's
independently wealthy because this home
on the beach she's a widow oh that's her
thing
she's also a high powered like the head
of some department at science tech
they're both yeah they both have high
paying jobs at
science and you know this was the 80s
where uh like 20 bucks would buy a beach
house
so yeah and then i love
uh david bruce bannon's um job he's even
harry kane he has a job within a job
because he's building an anti-hulk gun
to shoot the hulk out of himself
it's a transponder
excuse me but it's also get the science
right the way he's pitching he can't say
that to his uh corporate bosses what
he's saying is and what i believe to be
true is it's also an infinite energy
device he's also created the power of
gamma gamma radiation to just power the
world it's like just kidding i'm not
trying to help anybody else
it's a lot like doc ox spider-man 2 it's
like the pow it's like creating its own
sun to tap as an energy source yeah with
gamma radiation he just thinks the side
effect is if he blasts himself with it
it'll okay so it's a happy side effect
he's not or is he conning the world in
the [ __ ] i actually do
the implication i thought and i i only
watched this twice so please feel free
to go back and review it again but i
believe the implication was that he
didn't even start out like he just was
using his gamma knowledge to try to do
some good and then he was like oh hmm
interesting i bet a happy side effect if
i lay down in front of this yeah i bet
this might also dehulcify me a deal okay
got it all right good guy uh okay not a
guy who's big into planning in terms of
the sciences we're told from the very
beginning that his original plan of
blasting himself with the gabbard issue
was just designed to like untap the
human potential within us all it's like
is this was this a peer-reviewed study
sir i don't that doesn't sound very
science with science how does it sound
very official what university signed off
on this let's get away look out no
fabric is safe from the hulk lou
ferrigno returns with an even scarier
bowl cut and when this monster
bodybuilder finally comes out to play
he's showing off his signature move
grunt flexing
[Applause]
not looking good
[Applause]
[Applause]
for those of you that don't know uh
that's uh pumping iron yeah probably one
of the better documentaries or more
entertaining documentaries ever so great
uh young arnold schwarzenegger training
for his uh fourth mr olympia i think it
is
one of the mr universe yeah um
and it follows him and lou ferrigno and
his dad uh as they prepare for that
contest really really crucial viewing
and a different a different side of
arnold schwarzenegger there's there's a
lot of talk afterwards about like how
scripted how how much were they playing
for the cameras in pumping iron versus
how much of it is real but
schwarzenegger is sort of purposely
playing like a bully yes like he's very
much yeah like he's mean to ferrigno and
it's uh it's fascinating how his public
persona has totally changed from that
he's become a nicer guy i mean he
launched as a villain you know or
anti-hero at least a conan and yeah
and stuff like that that transformation
how in the 90s he became like cuddly
family man everybody's arnold is like
it's really fascinating when you go back
and watch bobby guy which is really
really hard he's got a harsh personality
he's a fascinating a-hole in that movie
yeah yeah that's really great oh so good
and then yes the the whatever is going
on between lou ferrigno and his dad is
so great in that whole thing uh you look
like michelangelo he's just very
supportive gotta butter up your spirit a
lot of positive support
i got a buffer the original like i love
my large song
yeah gotta oil up my big boy the
original guy who runs flex off suit
loved his large son all right keep going
these fans have wondered if a
live-action thor movie could work now
eric kramer has the answer no
meet the viking god with a hammer you
know from the comics but instead of
norse magic he's got nose magic get
promoting this nose of mine always find
my man super cab hailing powers
[Applause]
and an infectious laugh in that i think
he has some kind of disease where he
can't stop laughing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
do you think of the
uh the character of thor um
it's a little different uh he's still uh
he's been banished i think for the sin
of arrogance you know
he's
yeah they can't seem to decide what his
nature is because at first donald blake
a normal human stumbles into this cave
is he a normal human though or he's been
called to
dig up norse artifacts by some type of
and he's been like obsessed with like
viking stuff his whole life yeah he's
just like a regular ass doctor he's a
quirky twitch machine who finds himself
pulled somehow spiritually to this cave
where he finds the dead body the grave
of thor but when he first reads the
inscription on the grave it's like thor
was a human king
and then and now he's like a ghost or a
disembodied spirit but then later thor
self refers to himself as the son of
odin yeah so i'm not sure what he is
well and he like lives in the hammer he
lives in the hammer like a genie he
lives in the hamburglar hammer like a
genie and he describes yeah go ahead you
have to hold up the hammer and yell odin
and that's how you call thor yeah that's
the only way to get thor like out of the
hammer right and he basically describes
it as like uh
essentially i guess uh uh what's that
thing where you like lie in like one of
those baths and you can't oh it well it
seems yeah like a
sensory deprivation chamber yeah like in
stasis it's darker than that he
describes it like sleep paralysis like
you're just in this like cold dead
darkness and like no form no any kind of
like heroic or even nice person would
not banish him to the land of wind and
ghosts he would probably like let him
chill in his apartment while he went out
he's like i'm bored here blake send me
back to the nightmare void
yeah uh so yeah he has he lives in the
forbidden
shake weight that donald blake does
yeah the shake weight of mystery return
to odin yeah um it just i don't
understand how i mean i guess i get how
that would make for a good tv series as
donald blake gets into a scrape gets
into a jam summoned summons somewhere
and then um
but thor makes things complicated like
oh this guy again good boy right cause
like in the comics at that time uh that
it was like uh donald blake was thor
like thor was like trapped inside of him
the mjolnir was like donald blake's cane
and like blah blah blah
and so i guess in this one they were
like but what if it was a buddy comedy
yeah exactly and like he had to like
manage thor who's like yeah like i it's
interesting i think hemsworth is playing
this a little bit in the first thor
when he has the drink and he like slams
another like this is that thor
always wakes up uh angry and thirsty
yeah every time he comes out of the
hammer he's like i need oh yeah this is
pure like what if a viking woke up it
was just like you there get me mead yeah
oh good stuff yeah and he does he they
they do the throwing back his head
laughing [ __ ] so they hit that so hard
like
a few times and we get it this is like
constant
all right we get it he loves life keep
going first even the mighty thor bows
before donald blake my master waits in
his metal chariot instead of being
thor's alter ego like the comics donald
is this dweeb who everyone hates i like
you blake but only when you're asleep so
when are you leaving and who keeps thor
stuffed inside his hammer like a dog
being crate trained do i have your
permission to leave until one
unforgettable honky-tonkin
hootie-tooting knight on the towel makes
them best buddies
[Music]
it's like a four minute original song
should really be more songs about big
guys being big
drive home how big the guys are
[Laughter]
every lyric in the song is just about
the presence of a large guy big guys
look at this big guy he's in the
building now and he's big
and it's a biker bar there must be big
guys in there all the time yeah it must
be on loop um yeah and this is to set up
you know i guess the the promise of how
fun the thor tv show would be where
donald blake's like i'm a wiener i can't
go to a bar
there's anthony big guys there and then
thor goes haha come with me super like
80s like jock versus dweeb stuff yeah
that's really where we're going um and
like a and he's so
so dweeby like like an 80s babe like
slides up next to donald blake and he's
like i'm a babe and he's like oh god
i need a big guy
well luckily there's one right there
like no didn't you hear the song there's
one right over there yeah um so just uh
just a lot of fun um
a four minute long
fun time i feel like my hope is in thor
four if i walked into a barn immediately
they would start playing a song about
like look at this big fat piece of crap
you should leave this point
get back in your ham every time
you are bumming me out
no one wants to know there's stuff here
this bar is just for jocks
all right that's why i need a
i can't wait i wish they had cut over
and there was like a a a gated fence and
a band playing behind it like it wrote
like
one thing yeah that's the one thing
that's what this is every bar needs the
one thing that's missing is just like a
full-on bar band and they're all black
remember mcgee from the hulk show the
report on banner's trail no well fine he
was a relic of the 70s anyways and in
case you weren't aware this is the 80s
this is the 80s i don't know what a good
cause is anymore that means
there's something that's so funny to me
about saying that in 1988 like maybe if
you said that in 82 when the 80s was
like fresh and new and no one quite knew
what it was about at that point
but yeah i think me being like it's the
2000s people wake up yeah i feel like
that as a trope 80s and 90s were really
big on that and then it sort of you
don't hear it as much like it's the tens
man that's why because we don't have a
good word for it but yeah like the
naughty hotties yeah but every 90s movie
has that like this is the 90s mr bond
yeah we don't do that sort of thing
we live in a year
we live in a year yeah they were trying
to figure it out still um but yes this
is great uh they did have that um you
know kind of gumshoe reporter uh uh
tracking david banyan down across uh
that was so well hidden changing his
name that was the ticket keeping the
same job on the tv show had to keep
moving because this reporter mcgee was
like hot on his trail yeah
mcgee's got a very forgiving editor that
just keeps paying his expenses he just
travels from town to town not not ever
getting a story yeah well didn't he i'm
trying to remember at one point in this
movie isn't he like talking to the hotel
or something and being like i don't know
why that didn't go through or something
yeah no he's definitely like begging he
gets like caught off get cut off yeah
yeah
so
uh a holdover from
everyone's favorite the tv show i guess
six years later they just felt like they
had to they had to bring them in yeah
people are going to wonder where's mcgee
what of mcgee where where is he in all
this you know the fans spent a lot of
time on that and i just had the feeling
that i was right uh this must be from
the show because otherwise why are we
following why it's old he doesn't it
doesn't really pay off it's just like
remember there's another guy we can
bring back yeah
all right let's keep going
contracts deals negotiations squash
publicity stunts corporate espionage
compact players and because the pc-90s
are right around the corner who would
you prefer to be on our side thor or a
bunch of trigger-happy deputies even
marvel is starting to realize it's time
to add some diversity to their cast you
stupid cajun idiot hey you're just as
cajun as me man
i died i thought that was my favorite
part
with like the inexplicable occasion
accusation
there's that guy that actor jack napier
uh great actor great character actor uh
he's got a line later where he actually
does the paul prudhomme
this is halfway through the movie they
just go they just become so cajun the
funniest thing uh he's just like he
gonna come back and get his hope
oh my god that's the best thing i've
ever seen yeah because we're trying to
figure out like who the villain is
because obviously it's a team up movie
so first they have to fight each other
and but there's multiple corporate
executives it's like which one
it's a very needlessly confusing thing
about what the corporate espionage even
is because what happens is that the
younger brother doesn't feel like a man
this is a line in the movie yeah he
doesn't feel like a man so he hires
cajuns to go
kidnap um dr banyan and his uh d hulk
ray um
for reasons for reasons which is that he
is a man we should know you said they
were living in malibu obviously this was
all filmed in l.a it is supposed to be
new orleans like we we did they're
serious they do say no no no friggin way
no way they do set that up it's not
supposed to be california it very
obviously was all filmed in southern
california there's they are saying it's
louisiana
and that's why there are cajuns i
promise you this is true
i need to watch this again there's no do
mention that the lab is in new orleans
in one no i noticed it because i was
like that's weird that they would say
it's new orleans so obviously not
louisiana and then later cages show up
i'm like well that's right i guess i'm
thrown off because we see multiple
locations that we are around every day
we all as la residents recognize this is
los angeles but i in the in the film i
believe it is supposed to be the city of
new york
you're just as cajun as me
here is we're here in the french quarter
right now i can't believe you would say
that to me on bourbon street of all
places
[Laughter]
there's nothing about that movie that
that screams
i believe that i believe that is in my
nose today like is this in new orleans
wow amazing all right uh this changes
everything guaranteed keep going
you're here for action and this movie
will get to that when it's good and
ready
no wait
the show-stopping set pieces like thor
and hulk slowly wrestling around a
sparkle factory and a big fight
i guess that's how computers work yeah
what the people wanted to see
gingerly jogging away
that's clearly just not flying half the
time
and marvel's brand new cutting edge
special effect slow
motion
i think a full third of this is in this
zack snyder take notes choppy
[Applause]
that's my favorite yeah
wow that looks truly amazing it's too
bad everything else moves just as slow
[Music]
he's waking up still waking up
i love that i should have put that in it
it
doesn't cut away right there it slowly
fades into an image of the waves yes
it's a slow dissolve into the beach um
and while he's waiting to like maybe
de-hulk or kill himself like you're
watching it happen in real time before
donald blake is like hey i remember you
from school you were a guy yeah i want
to talk to you about norse stuff yeah
for no explicable reason
um
yeah that the pacing though i mean
that's a feature of just older things in
general uh they didn't have as many
quick cuts and stuff like that but i
feel like there were some particularly
egregious moments in this where they
just forgot they were waiting for
somebody to yell cut and they just never
did it's a 90-minute movie that could
have easily been an hour well i mean it
was tv so it was like they had a
two-hour slot 30 minutes of commercials
you got to fill the rest of that time
whether the script gets it done or not i
feel like there was that there are a few
scenes that feel like purposefully drawn
out because they just needed a little
filler yeah get to this next commercial
it's not enough good cajun stuff not
enough um and then the fighting is not
great i mean ferrigno looks the part but
you know he's a he's a bodybuilder he's
there to flex and eric kramer i don't
think is fighting i think they probably
sub him out for somebody else and it's
just really two guys just slowly tossing
each other yeah it's that very
it's that very 80s style of action like
tv action choreography where it's like
stuff doesn't really happen to the
actors that happens like around them
yeah like their sets will spark or like
guys will flip right like on the 18
you'll always recall like they would
shoot but they would shoot like the
boxes above the bad guys that fall on
the bad guys like it's a lot of that
stuff so you avoid the actors having to
do it there's something funny to me
though about because they fight each
other but otherwise they're going up
against goons you know and it's funny to
me to see thor and the hulk go up
against struggle cajun street struggle
against like two guys yeah yeah i don't
know if you need that much like
firepower that's like there's one scene
that i noted i don't know if we pulled
it at the trailer where it's literally
just hulk on the ground kind of just
like rolling around like trying to get
his bearings it's like this is just
undignified
he's he's a thanos level fighter like he
can look
like he's a turtle on his back or
something
okay let's keep playing
that could be the launch of an
interconnected marvel universe and i for
one am on board because who knows what
dc is doing with that new batman movie
can you believe they gave it to the guy
who made pb's big adventure and it stars
mr mom one eight hundred next year my
batman 89
starring
where's the beef oh there it is i dream
of weenie revenge of this nerd a woman
scientist
and thor's drinking problem i'm thirsty
is there nothing to drink in this
alchemist's den i want a drink mead oh
what you call beer will do i
need to drink
[Laughter]
dead noise
you should probably save that one for
thor four yeah you know better
girlfriend maggie has a superpower in
this too ignoring red flags
[Music]
naked with the dog that's um
yeah if i run into my boyfriend naked
outside my house hanging out with my dog
late at night i'mma have some questions
not but not even like you know like okay
let me explain you know like
[Laughter]
like you can't like non-verbal
that's where it's a concern
oh he knows how to party get over here
the dog stole all my clothes at least
like now we can have a conversation
thank you people for watching uh we're
gonna get to your questions right after
this uh but before we do click subscribe
click like
give that bell a ring ling ding ding and
you will never miss a thing including
our full scene by scene breakdown of
emmanuel in space coming soon coming
soon that's gonna be the first thing we
watch on twitch
we get to get to get to the song part
here we go yeah
elaine saritsky who what else did he
what else was he known for
[Music]
just the first line just give it give it
time
[Music]
oh a world of desire we forgot the
subtitles
i can't
how
how have i never seen this
did you not have cinematics
see we nailed it at a friend's house
did i have it in my room
but already they're just clearly in a
human bedroom
well didn't you have to go like she had
a horse why shouldn't medieval
she started uh she starts out on earth i
don't remember her i thought she was
doing it yeah the aliens kidnap emmanuel
and i think that they use her memories
to discover humans yeah they're studying
her to learn about human sexuality like
could you teach us to love so then they
just go into her spank bank yeah yeah
exactly yeah
the multiverse of spank bank yeah
exactly okay your questions are m's are
they about to ban you on space they
should
uh let's see i get over the thor from
the special movie becomes the dad and
good luck charlie yeah jason as gary
notes that uh the thor eric kramer
becomes the dead and good luck charlie
he's he's working together
works a lot you like you would recognize
him if you saw a picture of him today
yeah he doesn't look like stone cold
yes
the buzz does a lot but yeah he plays a
lot of like you know big big big guy big
guys in bars
when the big guy song comes on uh
panther brings us up uh lou ferrigno's
hulk met thor and daredevil which other
marvel character would you like to see
in matthew pair up with i i do want to
note uh john bailey was telling me about
this how great uh the trial of the
incredible hulk is which was the one
they made after this where he's on trial
i imagine um but uh his representation
is matt murdock
so there's a cool legal uh thriller
where matt murdock is representing the
hulk in court in 1989 or something i
feel like uh like uh hank pym or scott
lang like an ant-man would work in this
world oh i would love to see that both
personality-wise and yeah like the 80s
version of like just a there's one guy
who can shrink down real small and you
do honey i shrunk the kids yeah
yeah
he's tiny yeah you just borrow like uh
uh just borrow like a big chair from one
of them yeah exactly like like when you
know yeah like you know
i mean we were talking about this um i
don't know if it was last week or this
week but my god do i want the universe
where they made venom like a procedural
like eddie brock's venom in 1988 where
he was doing like he was a gumshoe
reporter who also was uh an alien
it was venom with venom at the same time
but just in this era and i want that to
cross over with the hulk
that would have been really fun because
he could have been trying to like
discover the key to the hulk and he's
like i also have a duty yeah instead of
mcgee um you have eddie brock right yeah
i think that could be really good yeah
um so that's my that's my match-up for
sure um so chuck farley asked the
question that everybody's been asking
themselves for decades is i never got
how the hulk's pants worked in that show
uh because everything else just flies
off right um like how do they not get
shredded because you gotta figure like
his his donk grows just as much as the
rest of it like a tree trunks yeah you'd
have to figure it out you'd at least get
the top button
like that's flying off and hitting
somebody if
he's growing to such an extent that the
shirt like busts apart like combusts
from the pressure at least the pants
would have to expand they're ripped
they're certainly ripped but he's just
getting like very powerful elastic bands
over his over his uh jeans i don't
understand like it's not that crazy to
have him in his underwear like that's
not
freaky i mean i don't know maybe i just
watch emmanuel too much but i think the
hulk's pants could fall off and we'd all
be fine
um all right uh mj pretzels are asked
when will we get australia commentaries
after dark which reviews the emmanuel
films
not the film i've really never seen any
of the emmanuel films i've only seen
this take on manuel in space
there's gonna be like one really sleazy
guy from the 90s like hey they're
playing my sword
that belongs to me yeah there's red shoe
entertainment's property
the red shoe diaries was another erotic
show from the same marriage a follow-up
question sort of from james bunt my
mother watched all the hulk show in
hopes that his pants would finally split
in his transformation when did you
realize your parents didn't understand
how tv was made i don't know she may she
may have uh understood a little more
than you uh james she might have been
waiting for hulk to hang dong yeah uh so
that
i won't finish that sentence
uh taika waititi keeps promising it's
gonna happen so one day one day soon
bruins fan 1144 uh notes this movie
needed a gambit for it to prove it's
into new orleans yes i was really
missing a guy
not enough cherie yeah not enough a lot
of people being called cherie
yeah yeah van damme in this as gambit
would have been just like wow cherry on
top so good
uh i guess we'll we'll close with this
uh haley uh hertzer s uh or says it's my
birthday today happy birthday haley
uh hope you have a great one um and
asking are you excited for nope yep
i'm very yep
i kind of wish like i wish i hadn't seen
the the final trailer i didn't i skipped
it i did they they've they've now given
one more thing that i wanted to know
away and i'm bummed out that i know it
but i'm still very excited oh well well
uh that dovetails nicely into your clue
for next week which is something that
i'm going to finish watching today
oh whoops
[Music]
all right
and who keeps thor stuffed inside his
hammer like a genie in a bottle except
instead of granting you wishes you'll
just wish he'd stop taking all the
ladies and drinking all of your beer
starring
the gods must be lazy
snow blake
donald trump
l.a shaw woodward and burnout
thorgen story
wow slow-mo even works for racquetball
scenes is there anything that this brand
new technology can't do
it's different between squash and
racquetball
is there anybody now are we not 80s
enough we're not 80s no okay
i kind of thought those were two words
for the same thing okay i will admit i
will admit that to you right now there
aren't there are no wasps on this panel
ah shucks
oh you don't know how to play squirrels
oh
you mean racquetball that's
unheard of at the club the club
[Music]
next week uh we'll be back um for
something that again i wish hadn't been
spoiled because it turns out there's a
big thing in it and uh uh nobody waited
for everyone else to finish before
talking about the big thing so that's
that's uh next week's uh clue for your
honest trailer um people are already
asking for it you can probably guess
what it is listen
you know what it's going to be
it's what you think it is yeah that's
the thing you think you're not gonna
miss it
we have fun here don't we all right i'm
gonna play our outro music and we will
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you